wirklich was dann wirklich problem war
es ist ein problem was was ist ein
wirkliches problem was jetzt einfach
gerade sehen und den gegenwind den jetzt
gerade verspürt der ist einfach die
konsequenz der wie es dir bisher gemacht
habt so einfach ist das als willkommene
neue leute und herzlich kommen zu der
quasi die fortsetzung des videos von
gestern ich habe gestern ein video über
diese ganze geschichte zwischen den
rangers und ohne gemacht weil ich eine
vergangenheit auch schon einige videos
über die per post gemacht hatte und ja
es sehr unterhaltsam fand wie sie auf
einmal so ihren stil bisschen switch
haben und ja dann haben die per post
gestern abend das muss kurz nachdem ein
video über sie online gekommen ist
gewesen sein ein video hochgeladen in
dem sie direkt auf die kritik von monte
ohne und der gewissermaßen auch die
kritik die ich vorgetragen habe reagiert
haben und das wollen wir uns jetzt
anschauen und man kann schon mal
vorneweg sagen leute es ist ein relativ
besonderer moment in der youtube
geschichte das hat sieht man auch gesagt
und da muss ich mal zugestimmt denn die
leute die über ewige zeit hinweg ohne
mit der wimper zu zucken game master
videos und forti nachts anrufen videos
gemacht haben sind jetzt zum ersten mal
offen und kommen aus dieser rolle raus
aber leute bevor wir sie wieder von
cassandra steen will ich mir noch ganz
kurz ein paar szenen aus dem
ursprünglichen video namens warum kommen
keine videos mehr von dem konkurs
anschauen denn da haben sie auch ein
zwei sachen gesagt die ja so ein
bisschen kritisch sind reaktionen und
sowas und ihr wisst ja ganz viel kunst
reagiert oder videos gemacht wir noch
nie was gesagt werden immer unsere
presse gehalten bisher ja okay die frage
ist auch so was was hättet ihr denn
gesagt also ich weiß nicht ob ich jetzt
an den kreis dazu zählt von leuten die
auf eure videos reagiert haben und wo
direktion auch gesehen habt keine ahnung
ist mir egal aber was wird er sagen so
also ihrem achten game master video ich
mache mich darüber lustig und so ist es
halt so schlecht gefegt was wollt ihr
dann sagen lasst den game master in ruhe
und er ist auch bei anderen zu kleine
unterwäsche viele clowns gesehen
irgendwie
also die meisten wissen eben in den
meisten videospiele mit der räume ok
damit gleich zwei kritische punkte ok
also erstens erstmal quasi die
beleidigung an kleiner youtuber in
deutschland die auf ihre videos reagiert
haben sich darüber lustig gemacht haben
auch da weiß ich wiederum nicht ob ich
da mit reinziehen keine ahnung so oder
so ist es eine relativ studie aussage
weil so jungs sind wir ganz ehrlich so
was erwartet ihr ist halt beide mitte 20
und macht videos in denen er so tut als
sei der game master echt oder ihr
facetime mit einem fiktiven charaktere
aus toy story so lasst das mal sacken
liegt glaube ich relativ nah dass manche
leute darüber lustig machen die meisten
wissen in den meisten videospielen der
räume und zudem zweiten part dass ihr
eine rolle spielt ihr seid die meisten
wissen dass ihr eine rolle spielt die
meisten außerhalb von eurem kanal ja
eure eigenen zuschauer
nein und ich glaube das was somit die
sache an der sich viele leute sterben
deswegen die grazer und gegenwind in
youtube deutschland bekommt weil er
einfach über sehr lange zeit hinweg
schaue nirgendwo so die gutgläubigkeit
und naivität oder sehr jungen zuschauer
aus genutzt habt und den halt relativ
schlecht gefakte videos präsentiert habe
wohl wissend dass diese zuschauerschaft
die ihr habt das nicht durchblicken kann
also ich würde bei jeder weiß ist dass
ihr eine rolle spielt vielleicht eure
eigenen zuschauer ausklammern aber
soviel dazu jetzt machen sprung und
schon in dem video von gestern abend
rand stehen einige lügen und
anschuldigungen brauchen die auf jeden
fall diesem video queren wollen deswegen
mein ganzes video und das ist das
einfach video wir gehen auf jeden punkt
1 von montreal und ein lächeln muss man
jetzt auch kritisch seien leute auch
kritisch mit sich selbst und das auch
das was ich in diesem video machen will
also frank gross und ohne sind so auch
so beiden extremen enden von dieser
diskussion jetzt gerade und ich werde
versuchen mich ein bisschen der
mittelposition ein bisschen kritisch zu
sein und zu mit dessen muss man sich
halt so gut erhalten okay gut jetzt
immerhin mal ein video wo sie ehrlich
mit der kamera reden und nicht so tun
als sei der game master echt ist schon
mal ein vortrag finde ich gut viele
liegen werden uns an den kopf geworfen
die wir nicht so stehen lassen möchten
und das einfach klären
so ein video wird es auch sehr selten
geben ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich
hab' ich persönlich gefreut so ein video
zu sehen wo die post hat einfach ein
bisschen mal aus ihrer rolle raus kann
man einfach mal ehrlich ihre meinung
sagen auch wenn es quasi wie video ist
in dem sie auf anschuldigung eingehen
aber für alle die sich jetzt mit mit
gefreut haben keine sorge leute wird ja
nicht allzu oft passiert in zukunft was
traurig ist das so lügen themen groß
gemacht wenn das traust du übrigens
reichweite macht ihr so kleine hoch und
das ist auch der grund warum auf
kleinere kann er nicht beantwortet haben
die soe gerieben
soll ich mir wird es auch strafbar so
liegen wir ganz zu verbreiten okay okay
okay okay okay mal ein bisschen laufen
also ich glaube dass calvin auf der
rechten seite der so bis zum world
abwärts wird sich bisschen darüber
aufregt was er ist mit lügen meint und
kleine kanäle wie groß gemacht werden
von onkel zum beispiel ist diese
geschichte dass sie sich angeblich mit
einem 16 jährigen mädchen treffen wollte
musste starten ich habe bewusst
angeblich weil ganz eindeutige weise
immer noch nicht erbracht sind aber ja
an der stelle wenn ich direkt mal eins
vorneweg schicken
für den fall dass die post das hier
sehen jungs ihr müsst euch einfach nicht
wundern okay ihr habt über monate wenn
nicht jahre hinweg content gemacht der
sehr viele leute getriggert hat war ja
einfach ganz bewusst man muss es einfach
so sagen halt videos geschickt habt im
wissen dass eure sehr junge zuschauer
schafft das richtig blicken kann euch
das glaubt soll da muss man sich einfach
nicht wundern reden wir mal über das
video mit dem lieferanten wo ja fünf mal
irgendwie beim selben lieferservice
angeblich bestellt hat ihr redet davon
dass eine rolle spielt ok puncto game
master kann ich das vielleicht ein ganz
kleines bisschen nachvollziehen dass sie
sagt ja okay wir tun so als seien der
game master echt weil das ist eine rolle
euro zum shorttrack es trotzdem nicht
aber okay aber wo ist das rolle spielen
bei dem video wo ihr gefaked habt dass
ihr fünf mal bei einem lieferservice
bestellt oder vier mal ich weiß es nicht
besteht dass rolle spielen darin dass
einer von euch sich selbst spielt und
der andere so tut als wäre der pizzabote
ist dass das was mit rolle spielen
gemeint ist
das ist die vision projektes wir haben
wir alles schon geplant und last und das
dass wir so eine gehörige zuschauer sind
das eine abartige charakter von dir dass
du jetzt wieder dicht auf dieser
position zu behaupten dass simon
gehirnwäsche betreibt ist fanny man muss
sagen so ich bin mir sicher dass die man
weiß wie die leute von seiner meinung
überzeugt aber das glaube ich von euch
auch so ist auch schon wieder über so
eine sache reden müsste damit euch mehr
leute das glauben als vorher aber leute
nummer fotoreporter achtjährigen
zuschauern zu erzählen dass der game
master echt ist oder das vorrecht ist
und dann mit der aufmerksamkeit die man
daraus gewinnt videos zu machen das ist
nicht gehirnwäsche das ist unterhaltung
ok also hast du es war ja früher gaming
kanal da wo wir keine ahnung ein halbes
jahr da fassten ja nix mehr hochgeladen
haben sagen game content ohne wichtiger
quasi tot wir haben alle videos dann
gelöscht beziehungsweise auch privat
genommen und dann neu angefangen sms zu
machen
das ist jetzt dieser muss für sie kritik
bekommen haben dass sie ihren gaming
kanal quasi umfunktioniert haben in den
sma kanal und das zwar mit recht
ordentlichen klicks muss man sagen aber
hat mit miserablen bewertungen das ding
ist wenn der kanal sonst geht ruck
gelassen weil wir ja keine gaming videos
mehr produziert haben und warum dann
nicht einfach den kanal umbenennen oder
nicht schon ein paar abonnenten drauf
sind wie uns feiern wir hätten die
gelten sollte ist entweder in stuttgart
wurde content natürlich der passende für
sie ist aber wir sind allerdings ist
aktiv und man kann ja immer noch
dominieren den kanal einerseits muss ich
sagen kann man schon verstehen dass man
sagt okay wir wollen neuen kanal machen
und wir haben einen toten gaming kanal
mit einer halben million abonnenten so
benutzen wir den vielleicht dafür so der
gedankengang macht ein stück weit schon
sind aber gleichzeitig beschweren sich
die project fonds darüber dass wenn sie
auf ihrem langjährigen gaming kanal ja
auch wenn sie gar keine videos bisher
hochgeladen haben jetzt auf einmal sma
videos die sie hochladen das ist ein
dislike so obviously aber ja die ganz
wichtige sache die simon in seinem video
auch angebracht hat ist der verweis auf
den amerikanischen kanal namens the
shower sma und ich hab da mal die videos
von diesem sektor aufgemacht weil es da
mal das gerücht im raum ist dass die
preisrichter vielleicht bedient ich habe
zehn mal so die videos von 6 kanal und
die letzten 50 60 videos oder so mal
rausgesucht und werde jetzt ein abgleich
mit dem ios lieblos gemacht haben wir
einfach nur die panels an
wir sehen oben in der ecke steht erstmal
immer schwarzer hintergrund essen im
vordergrund viele gelbes essen oranges
essen gesichter recht nahe
ja ja ist schon recht deutliche
ähnlichkeit da und will damit ich das
argument gemacht wird ja so jeder sma
kanal sieht so aus muss man ja so machen
service ist angegeben lustigerweise sind
hier zwei videos von 6 direkt darunter
in frankfurt wieder so die sind schon
recht ähnlich vergleich dazu mal das
video hier von rsm abfahren so da sind
halt bunt sachen drauf so der
hintergrund ist die schwarz ja sie hat
auch erst mal drauf beschrieb er sieht
ganz anders aus wenn wir jetzt mal
schaut davon sektor waren wir von sma
bros es ist einfach es ist einfach
ehrlich so effekt ist so oder hier unten
ses es immer auch ein e smart hat man
sich ganz anders aus aber ich will dich
da er lange drauf rumreiten gleich wie
immer ab okay denn aktuelles video heißt
erste mal dabei war vor einer woche bei
6 m a double cheeseburger dann hier sma
fried chicken und spicy feier noodles
dann muss ich auch nicht weil die suche
vor einer woche erst am abend feiern
noodles und schicken also man kann sagen
was man will da ist schon eine krasse
ähnlichkeit
aber ok weiter im text alle in englisch
orissa gesamte kanal auf englisch ist so
darf man natürlich international mal ein
bisschen was erreichen muss man das nur
in deutschland um sein wenn man deutsch
spricht das gute ist wir sprechen oder
ähnlich das heißt nein muss man nicht
aber die ganze sache wirkt einfach wie
so ein mega abgekartet hat business move
so ok gaming kanal ja egal scheiß drauf
machen jetzt aus dem deutschen gaming
kanal internationalen englischen erster
kanal so klar kann man das machen so
wird euch keine anklagen deswegen aber
ist einfach schon notiert sowie sagt er
nicht er von neuen kanal aufgemacht
hätte man sich nicht denken können dass
leute auf euren gaming kanal die euch
beim zocken deutsch reden hören wollen
das scheiße finden wenn ihr sachen in
euch rein schaufelt und die geräusche
aufnimmt und nichts sagt man das ist auf
einmal englisch große überraschung und
daran hat man auch du willst einfach
dies sagt ohne behinderung und weil so
auch die bösen wiederum die wollen jetzt
da ist ja absolut
also jungs ganz im ernst ich habs gerade
eben schon gesagt so ihr braucht euch
halt wirklich nicht wundern so ist doch
klar ist doch klar so ihr habt einfach
die ganze zeit so euren film
durchgezogen seit überhaupt nicht
irgendwie kritik eingegangen habe weiter
eure game master videos gemacht game
master im schwimmbad keine ahnung game
master verfolgt uns game master kampf
ich weiß es nicht während andere sich
darüber lustig gemacht haben so
natürlich trigger dass die leute was
denkt ihr denn warum sich leute
reaktionen anschauen wo menschen sich
über eure videos lustig machen
offensichtlicher weise finden sehr viele
auch youtube zuschauer in deutschland
solche videos halt einfach lustig oder
zum darüber lustig machen so und werden
das für ewigkeit gemacht hat und einfach
nie auf kritik eingegangen seien einfach
weiteren film durchgeschoben habt
natürlich haben leute so ein bisschen
hass auf euch oder bisschen was gegen
euch vielleicht ein negativer
voreinstellung darüber darüber kann man
sich wirklich nicht wundern versucht
hilfs kleine ding gegen uns zu
verschlucken was dann wirklich das
problem was ist ein problem
abgesehen von den videos umsonst was du
was ist ein problem mit werden dass wenn
du so etwas was ist ein wirkliches
problem ich glaube ganz ehrlich leute
frank browser ich glaube nicht dass
irgendeiner wirklichen persönliches
problem mit euch hat auf dieser
plattform so was jetzt einfach gerade
sieht und den gegenwind den jetzt gerade
verspürt der ist aber die konsequenz der
wir bisher gemacht haben
so einfach ist das jetzt wissen über
spitz gesprochen aber das ist so als
würde ich drei jahre lang auf youtube
videos hochladen wie ich mir jeden tag
fleisch rein schiebe und sage wie geil
ist das fleisch zu essen und whatever
tiere zu essen so und dann nach drei
euro
die vegane hassen mich ganz ehrlich die
veganer wenn wir mal am tisch sitzen was
ist was ein problem was was ist ein
wirkliches problem ich kann es mir
einfach nicht erklären
die haben schon seit sieben monaten
machen ja bloß kanal und das wusstet ihr
auch ganz genau ist doch nicht so als ob
ich jetzt gar nicht kennen weil ich
wusste dass nicht geerdet ist auch eine
stelle wo sie man gut abgedeckt hat ich
habe es im letzten video auch schon
gesagt ihr habt doch er doch was im kopf
oder sonst würdet ihr auch nicht so
seine seite denkt ihr wirklich ihr habt
den kanal einfach umbenannt
ohne geguckt zu haben vorher wer heißt
jeder youtuber macht als ich angefangen
habe youtube so da war ich wirklich so
ein kleiner pisser der keine ahnung von
social media youtube bot erwartet so wie
ich habe damals jeden kanal nahmen den
ich mir für mich überlegt habe gesucht
vorher weil ich mir sagen dass ich mit
zwei millionen das nicht macht ich kann
nicht sagen was die wahrscheinlichkeit
geschichte ist ihr habt euch ja gedacht
okay wenn eine bank rosso der kanal ist
gaming broß ja dann muss der sma kanal
er ist immer groß heißt macht ja sein
okay google war auf youtube sma bloß ein
ja okay gibt schon kanal scheiß drauf
das ist bisschen schlüssiger meinen
augen von jetzt können wir zu dem
richtigen thema nämlich dazu dass da ein
video im raum war
oder immer noch im raum ist von diesem
weg das suggeriert dass calvin sich mit
einer 16 jahren treffen wollte und das
ist etwas mit ihr machen wollte
darauf gehen jetzt einfach kurz warum
ich so dumm bin weil es gab diesen
personen wirklich wo die übrigens
volljährig die kann schon vorjahr und
ich musste mich dass geködert werden
dass die da so sich besprechen genau
also in dieser aktion haben sehr viele
leute mitgespielt
ok also ja die broschüren das jetzt so
als gäbe es da irgendwie so eine recht
große gruppe von leuten die was gegen
sie hat diese früher auch was gegen sie
hatte dass du dass diese gruppe an
leuten irgendwie ein mädchen
angesprochen hat mit der kälber
geschrieben hat und dann hat sie ihn
wieder angeschrieben und erst dann
darauf eingehe und kamen dann dahin und
danach hat dieses mädchen an ersten em
account reingeschrieben 16 jahre alt
oder somit bloß zu stellen
das ist wirklich ein ganz ganz
verrücktes thema dazu muss man auch
sagen so die post im laufe des wie es
jetzt sehr geehrt und verwenden auch
öfter so den ausdruck
ja ich würde es nicht aussprechen weil
kanal dann machten auf straßen fahren
kann kein bock darauf also quasi
menschen die keiner wirklich angezogen
sind von kindern und tun so als hätte
man sie als pds bezeichnet was halt so
überhaupt keinen sinn mache es macht
wirklich keinen sinn und es einfach
falschen verdrehen von tatsachen zu
behaupten dass leute euch in diese ecke
geschoben hätten weil solche leute pr
die hausse sind menschen die an nicht
körperlich entwickelten kindern
interessiert sind ja und wenn man sich
mit der 16-jährigen trifft oder
angeblich trifft sodann dann ist die
16-jährige einer person die hat
körperlich schon entwickelt ist so das
ok deswegen hat es mit dem wort gar
nichts zu tun
wer alles isoliert da mitgespielt und
calvin zu ködern ganz genau und da stand
im profil noch nichts von 16 oder 17
also dort ihr merkt die ganze sache
jetzt mega crazy vor allem diese story
mit diesem 16 jährige mädchen oder
angeblich 16 jährigen mädchen in dem
punkt muss man einfach wirklich auf
weitere beweise warten so aber die sache
ist ihr beiden ihr dürft euch hat
wirklich nicht wundern so ich würde mich
selbst auch ärgern wenn ich in einer
situation wäre das safe aber irgendwo
wenn man kritisch nachdenken darf man
sich jetzt einfach nicht unter näherte
vorgeschichte auf youtube und ihr habt
grund genug gegeben dass da ein raum auf
youtube entsteht indem youtuber sind und
zuschauer sind die halt eure inhalte
quasi lächerlich finde jetzt in der
front an euch aber die sich halt gern
darüber lustig machen wollen und dass
diese leute nicht gut zu sprechen sind
so obviously ist doch klar und ja
vielleicht wer fragt ihr euch viel zu
klein bisschen mehr so in dem was ihr
macht und den christen kritisch darüber
nach vielleicht macht das ist ja gerade
schon fakt ist dass tatsächlich der
grund dafür dass sie jetzt keine game
master videos gemacht also der prozess
hat er scheinbar schon angefangen sonst
würde er wahrscheinlich dieses ernste
video gar nicht machen vielleicht geht
dieser prozesse noch weiter wir kommen
irgendwann einen punkt an wo ich mir
ohne ironischen frank boss video geben
kann
aber bis dahin bleibt weiter im blick
leute was ich einfach so machen ich habe
hier unten einfach vorgestellt das video
verlinkt hier oben könnte man klar
abonnieren durch die sich unterhalten
hat haben wir gerne eure meinung zu
diesem thema die kommentare sind sehr
umfassend ja und bis dahin macht's gut
geschlagen hieß